Vancouver Island, known for its breathtaking scenery, astonishing postcard beauty and amazing wildlife, heaven on earth. But on certain parts of the island, beneath the beauty, some will tell you there lies a dark underbelly. And in the early hours of the morning, June 30th, 2002, that underbelly came to the surface. Lisa Marie Young was born on the 5th of May 1981. She lived in Nanaima, a city on Vancouver Island, in British Columbia, Canada. She lived with her parents, Dawn and Joanne Young and her two younger brothers.
温哥华岛以其令人叹为观止的风景、惊人的明信片般的美景和神奇的野生动物而闻名，简直是人间天堂。但在岛上的某些地方，在这份美丽之下，有些人会告诉你，那里隐藏着黑暗的一面。2002年6月30日清晨，这一面浮出了水面。丽莎·玛丽·杨（Lisa Marie Young）出生于1981年5月5日。她住在加拿大不列颠哥伦比亚省温哥华岛的纳奈莫市。她与父母道恩（Dawn）和乔安妮·杨（Joanne Young）以及两个弟弟住在一起。
Lisa was so sweet and gentle, very loving and protective of her younger brothers. If anybody ever had a problem, Lisa would always be there for them. She was a good listener, a beautiful and vibrant person. She did have a fiery side as well though. Lisa would never argue for the sake of arguing, but she always stood up for what she believed in. Lisa enjoyed hanging out with friends, dancing, water skiing, playing basketball and roller blading.
丽莎非常甜美温柔，对两个弟弟充满爱心且极具保护欲。如果有人遇到困难，丽莎总是会伸出援手。她是一个很好的倾听者，一个美丽而充满活力的人。不过，她也有火爆的一面。丽莎从不为了争吵而争吵，但她总是坚持自己的信念。丽莎喜欢和朋友们出去玩、跳舞、滑水、打篮球和溜旱冰。
As athletic as she was, she also enjoyed music and painting. On Saturday 29th June 2002, Lisa, who was 21 at the time, was at home. She lived in an apartment with a roommate next door to her parents, but she was moving out into a new apartment the next day, Sunday. Lisa was looking forward to the future. Not only was she moving to a new place, but she was also starting a new job later that week at a call centre. She had plans to go back to school too, with the aim to become a TV sports announcer.
除了运动天赋，她还喜欢音乐和绘画。2002年6月29日星期六，当时21岁的丽莎在家。她和室友住在一间公寓里，就在父母家隔壁，但第二天（星期日）她就要搬进新公寓了。丽莎对未来充满期待。她不仅要搬到新住处，那周晚些时候还要在一家呼叫中心开始一份新工作。她还计划重返校园，目标是成为一名电视体育播音员。
But first, it was time to party. It was the Canada Day long weekend, and one of Lisa's friends was also celebrating his birthday. His name is Dallas Hully. Lisa left at pretty late. It was 11pm that Saturday night when she left her parents' apartment and mentioned she was heading out. Her parents were worried, saying it was too late, especially since she was moving the
但首先，是时候去派对了。那是加拿大国庆日的长周末，丽莎的一位朋友也在庆祝生日。他的名字叫达拉斯·赫利（Dallas Hully）。丽莎离开得很晚。那天星期六晚上11点，她离开父母的公寓，说她要出门了。她的父母很担心，说太晚了，尤其是考虑到她第二天还要搬家。
next day. But Lisa told them not to worry, she would be fine. Lisa made her way to the Jungle Night Club on Skinner Street in downtown Nanaimo. It's now called Club 241. She arrived there just before midnight. Lisa actually used to work in the club. Police say it wasn't a place they readily associated with trouble. Being a long weekend, downtown was a happening place, there were people out everywhere having
但丽莎告诉他们不用担心，她会没事的。丽莎前往位于纳奈莫市中心斯金纳街（Skinner Street）的丛林夜总会（Jungle Night Club）。它现在叫241俱乐部（Club 241）。她在午夜前到达那里。丽莎其实以前在那个俱乐部工作过。警方表示，这并不是他们通常认为会出麻烦的地方。因为是长周末，市中心非常热闹，到处都是出来玩的人。
a good time. There were no problems inside the club, Lisa was just having fun with her friends. Lisa left the club about 2am. She walked out into the parking lot with her friend, Dallas Hully, and another male friend. They were hanging around outside talking and laughing, when one of Lisa's friends struck up a conversation with another male person, also hanging out in the parking lot. No one in the group knew who this male person was, but he seemed friendly enough. And they were most impressed with his car, which was an older model, Red Jaguar.
大家玩得很开心。俱乐部里没有发生任何问题，丽莎只是和朋友们玩得很开心。丽莎大约凌晨2点离开俱乐部。她和朋友达拉斯·赫利以及另一位男性朋友一起走到停车场。他们在外面闲逛、聊天、大笑，这时丽莎的一位朋友开始与另一名也在停车场闲逛的男性交谈。小组里没有人认识这个男人，但他看起来很友好。他们对他的车印象最深，那是一辆老款的红色捷豹。
Lisa, Dallas, and their other friend mentioned they wanted to go to a house party. The male they just met in the Red Jaguar offered to drive them, and they accepted the lift. They headed to the house party where they stayed for about an hour, before deciding they wanted to move on to another house party in the Cathers Lake area. The male in the Red Jaguar again offered to drive them. Lisa and her friends accepted. Shortly after arriving at the second house party, Lisa mentioned she was hungry and wanted something to eat.
丽莎、达拉斯和他们的另一位朋友提到他们想去参加家庭派对。刚认识的那位开红色捷豹的男子主动提出开车送他们，他们接受了。他们前往家庭派对，在那里待了大约一个小时，然后决定去凯瑟斯湖（Cathers Lake）地区的另一个家庭派对。开红色捷豹的男子再次提出开车送他们。丽莎和她的朋友们接受了。到达第二个家庭派对后不久，丽莎提到她饿了，想吃点东西。
The male in the Red Jaguar overheard the conversation and offered to drive Lisa to get some food. Lisa accepted his offer. Lisa's friends remained at the party. The reason for this happening was that Lisa was a vegetarian. Her friends were not, and so they were happy to eat the food that was at the party. But Lisa couldn't eat what was there, and wanted to go and get a vegetarian meal. So she jumped in the Red Jaguar, alone, with the male driver. About 4.30 am, Lisa made a call to her friend, Dallas, who was still at the party.
开红色捷豹的男子听到了谈话，主动提出开车带丽莎去买点吃的。丽莎接受了他的提议。丽莎的朋友们留在了派对上。发生这种情况的原因是丽莎是素食主义者。她的朋友们不是，所以他们很高兴吃派对上的食物。但丽莎吃不了那里的东西，想去买一份素食。于是她独自一人跳上了那辆红色捷豹，和男司机一起离开了。凌晨4点30分左右，丽莎给还在派对上的朋友达拉斯打了一个电话。
Lisa said the male in the Red Jaguar had taken her to a house, and she was uncomfortable with the situation. She didn't like the house, or who was there, and she wasn't being allowed to leave. That was the last her friends heard from her. Later that day, Sunday 30th June, Don and Joanne were supposed to be helping Lisa move, but they hadn't heard from her, and they were starting to worry. They tried calling her phone several times, but it just kept ringing out. They checked with Lisa's roommate, and started to panic when she told them Lisa never came
丽莎说开红色捷豹的男子把她带到了一所房子里，她对这种情况感到不安。她不喜欢那所房子，也不喜欢那里的人，而且他们不让她离开。那是她朋友们最后一次收到她的消息。那天晚些时候，6月30日星期日，道恩和乔安妮本应帮丽莎搬家，但他们一直没收到她的消息，开始担心起来。他们多次拨打她的电话，但一直无人接听。他们询问了丽莎的室友，当室友告诉他们丽莎从未回家时，他们开始惊慌失措。
home. There was no sign of her. Joanne and Don walked inside Lisa's apartment, and found her personal phone book. They called every single number inside it. But nobody had seen or heard from Lisa since the night before. Joanne and Don immediately knew something was wrong. Lisa was completely out of character. Lisa would always answer her phone, or at least call to let them know where she was.
她不见踪影。乔安妮和道恩走进丽莎的公寓，找到了她的个人电话簿。他们拨打了里面的每一个号码。但自前一天晚上以来，没有人见过或听过丽莎的消息。乔安妮和道恩立刻意识到出事了。这完全不像丽莎的作风。丽莎总是会接电话，或者至少会打电话告诉他们她在哪里。
Especially since she had enlisted their help to move that day. She wouldn't just take off without telling anyone. Joanne and Don called the police. The officer who took the call wasn't overly helpful. She's only been missing for a short time. You'll have to call back in 48 hours. Joanne and Don weren't waiting. They decided to take matters into their own hands, calling friends and family members,
尤其是因为她那天还请他们帮忙搬家。她绝不会在不告诉任何人的情况下就这么离开。乔安妮和道恩报了警。接电话的警官并没有提供太多帮助。她失踪的时间还很短。你们得48小时后再打来。乔安妮和道恩没有等待。他们决定自己采取行动，打电话给朋友和家人，
and organising their own search for Lisa. They felt as though they couldn't just sit there, they had to do something. And it worked in a way, because the police did end up sending someone around that night to take a report. An officer from the local Royal Canadian Mounted Police attended. The officer asked some questions and took a photo of Lisa to add to the report. But still, Joanne and Don weren't satisfied. They got the impression from the officer who attended that he wasn't that interested.
并组织他们自己的搜寻行动。他们觉得不能就这样坐以待毙，必须做点什么。这在某种程度上奏效了，因为警方确实在当晚派人过来做了笔录。当地皇家骑警的一名警官到场了。警官问了一些问题，并拿走了丽莎的照片加入报告。但乔安妮和道恩仍然不满意。他们从到场的警官那里得到的印象是，他对此并不感兴趣。
The RCMP that came to see us that Sunday night of the 1st of July has said, OK, well, keep in touch, I'll be back to work in four days, which would be like a Friday or something. He has said, and I was horrified, you know, I thought, like, what, she's missing now. I want people out there now looking for my daughter. So they decided to contact the local media. They were interested. A reporter arrived straight away, and at the next day, Lisa's disappearance made the news.
7月1日那个星期日晚上来看我们的皇家骑警说，好吧，保持联系，我四天后回来上班，那大概是星期五左右。他说完，我感到非常震惊，你知道，我想，什么，她现在失踪了。我现在就需要人们出去寻找我的女儿。所以他们决定联系当地媒体。媒体很感兴趣。一名记者立刻赶到，第二天，丽莎失踪的消息就上了新闻。
A few days later, Joanne and Don were told the serious crime unit had taken over the case. This was both good and bad news. At least now, Lisa's disappearance was being taken seriously. But the fact that the serious crime unit was in charge of the investigation wasn't encouraging. So the big question is, who was the man in the red jaguar? Well, he was actually identified. Christopher Adair is his name. He was born in 1975, making him 27 the night Lisa disappeared.
几天后，乔安妮和道恩被告知重案组已经接手了此案。这既是好消息也是坏消息。至少现在，丽莎的失踪得到了重视。但重案组负责调查这一事实并不令人鼓舞。所以最大的问题是，那个开红色捷豹的男人是谁？好吧，他确实被确认了。他的名字叫克里斯托弗·阿代尔（Christopher Adair）。他出生于1975年，丽莎失踪那晚他27岁。
Chris had been in some trouble with the law. He had charges for fraud, assault, traffic matters, and for bridging court orders. Police brought Chris in for questioning the month after Lisa's disappearance, July 2002. While he was at the station, Joanne Young, Lisa's mother, says she was brought in as well to confront Chris. This is not confirmed by the police, but Joanne says it happened. She was taken into the interrogation room where Chris was being questioned. There was a large photo of Lisa on the whiteboard.
克里斯曾惹过一些法律麻烦。他有欺诈、袭击、交通违规和违反法院命令的指控。丽莎失踪后的那个月，即2002年7月，警方将克里斯带去审问。丽莎的母亲乔安妮·杨说，她也被带去与克里斯对质。这一点未得到警方证实，但乔安妮说确实发生了。她被带进了审讯室，克里斯正在那里接受审问。白板上有一张丽莎的大照片。
Next to the photo were three words, rape, murder, and accident. Joanne asked Chris to tell her where Lisa was. Chris replied, I can't. There was a pause before he continued with, I'm sorry, I don't mean to disrespect your family. Chris then trailed off. Joanne says the meeting was only brief, and that she was surprised when she saw Chris. He didn't look or seem like a monster, just a normal guy.
照片旁边写着三个词：强奸、谋杀和意外。乔安妮要求克里斯告诉她丽莎在哪里。克里斯回答说，我不能。停顿了一下，他继续说，对不起，我无意冒犯你们家人。克里斯随后声音渐弱。乔安妮说这次会面很短暂，当她看到克里斯时感到很惊讶。他看起来并不像个怪物，只是个普通人。
Whatever account Chris gave to police in that interview room is unknown. What he said happened when he was with Lisa has never been made public. But whatever his story was, it was good enough for him to be released without charge. An examination of his vehicle by police failed to uncover any evidence suggesting foul play. However, there were whispers around town that the red jaguar had been stained cleaned before the police got anywhere near it. Chris has always remained a person of interest. Even years later, in media reports, police have made appeals to the public that anyone
克里斯在审讯室里对警方说了什么不得而知。他所说的与丽莎在一起时发生的事情从未公开过。但无论他的故事是什么，都足以让他被无罪释放。警方对他的车辆进行的检查未能发现任何暗示犯罪的证据。然而，镇上有传言说，在警方接近那辆红色捷豹之前，它就已经被清洗过了。克里斯一直是一个受关注的对象。即使多年后，在媒体报道中，警方仍向公众呼吁，任何
who may have seen the red jaguar that night in a suspicious area or idling for an extended period of time to immediately come forward. I should clarify, the red jaguar wasn't Chris's vehicle that belonged to his grandmother, Geraldine Adair, also known as Jerry. Jerry was a powerful and prominent realtor and a businesswoman in the town of Qualicum Beach, also located on Vancouver Island, less than an hour's drive away from Nanaimo. She promoted and sponsored many organisations, local groups and charities. There are some reports that suggest Jerry told the police her grandson Chris had nothing
可能在那晚在可疑区域看到红色捷豹或长时间怠速的人立即站出来。我应该澄清一下，那辆红色捷豹不是克里斯的车，那是属于他祖母杰拉尔丁·阿代尔（Geraldine Adair）的，也被称为杰瑞（Jerry）。杰瑞是温哥华岛夸利库姆海滩（Qualicum Beach）镇上一位有权势且杰出的房地产经纪人和女商人，距离纳奈莫不到一小时车程。她推广并赞助了许多组织、当地团体和慈善机构。有一些报道称，杰瑞告诉警方她的孙子克里斯与丽莎的失踪无关，如果他们继续骚扰他，她将采取法律行动。
to do with Lisa's disappearance, and if they kept harassing him, she would take legal action. Jerry sold her red jaguar after Chris was declared a person of interest, but it had already been examined by police at that stage. John and Joanne Young had organised posters to go up appealing for anyone with information about Lisa to come forward. After learning that police had identified the driver of the red jaguar, they updated the posters, naming Chris Adair. When the police learnt that the posters had been updated with Chris's name, they urged
在克里斯被列为受关注对象后，杰瑞卖掉了她的红色捷豹，但当时警方已经检查过它了。约翰和乔安妮·杨组织了海报，呼吁任何有丽莎信息的人站出来。在得知警方已经确认了红色捷豹司机的身份后，他们更新了海报，写上了克里斯·阿代尔的名字。当警方得知海报上更新了克里斯的名字时，他们敦促
the Youngs to reconsider. The Youngs didn't reconsider and went ahead with the posters. No one refused to display them. The police are still treating Lisa as a missing person. They say the investigation is ongoing. They suspect she met with foul play, but they refuse to make further comment. It does seem odd that so much information is known about Lisa's last movements. They know who she left the party with, and they know she was taken to a house.
杨氏夫妇重新考虑。杨氏夫妇没有重新考虑，继续张贴海报。没有人拒绝展示它们。警方仍将丽莎视为失踪人员。他们说调查仍在进行中。他们怀疑她遭遇了不测，但拒绝发表进一步评论。丽莎最后行踪的已知信息如此之多，这确实很奇怪。他们知道她和谁一起离开派对，也知道她被带到了一所房子里。
If you've listened to Episode 14, The Case on Helen Munnings, it was a similar story there. Police know who she was with before she disappeared. But there is no trace of her. They can't prove exactly what happened. The last court appearance Chris Adair made in British Columbia was on the 11th of October, 2002. He was charged with assaulting a peace officer in Yorkden, in the province of Saskatchewan. Over 1,000 miles away.
如果你听过第14集《海伦·曼宁斯案》（The Case on Helen Munnings），那里的故事很相似。警方知道她在失踪前和谁在一起。但她毫无踪迹。他们无法证明到底发生了什么。克里斯·阿代尔在不列颠哥伦比亚省的最后一次出庭是在2002年10月11日。他被指控在萨斯喀彻温省的约克顿（Yorkden）袭击了一名治安官。距离超过1000英里。
That assault occurred in August 2002, two months after Lisa disappeared. For whatever reason though, he appeared in an Animo court in relation to the charge on the 11th of October. He may have left Yorkden before justice caught up with him there and returned to Animo where he was picked up for it. Whatever the reason, that is the end of his criminal record and court appearances in British Columbia, because Chris packed up and moved away. So whose house did Chris take Lisa to?
那次袭击发生在2002年8月，即丽莎失踪两个月后。但出于某种原因，他于10月11日就该指控在纳奈莫法院出庭。他可能在正义追上他之前就离开了约克顿，回到了纳奈莫，在那里被捕。无论原因是什么，这都是他在不列颠哥伦比亚省犯罪记录和出庭的终点，因为克里斯收拾行装搬走了。那么克里斯把丽莎带到了谁的房子里呢？
Nothing has ever been officially released. But if you do enough searching on this case, you will come across this line. Everyone knows what happened. It is believed by many that when he offered Lisa a ride to get food, Chris took her to a house only 10 minutes away from the party they were at. And as you've already heard, Lisa expressed discomfort with what was happening and where she was taken to. What happened once Lisa and Chris reached this location is said to involve men who are notorious
没有任何官方消息发布。但如果你对这个案件进行足够的搜索，你会看到这样一句话：每个人都知道发生了什么。许多人认为，当他提出开车带丽莎去买吃的时，克里斯把她带到了离派对只有10分钟路程的一所房子里。正如你已经听到的，丽莎对正在发生的事情以及她被带到的地方表示不安。据说丽莎和克里斯到达这个地点后发生的事情涉及在纳奈莫地区臭名昭著的男人。
around the Animo area. Men with extensive criminal associations. And there are persistent rumours of links to crime gangs. But it wasn't just those men said to be responsible. Others are said to be involved with what happened to Lisa, including a woman referred to as the clean-up girl. A bit of background on Animo at the time of Lisa's disappearance. It is reported that there was a thriving drug trade that existed there.
与广泛的犯罪组织有关联的男人。而且一直有关于犯罪团伙联系的传言。但据说不仅是那些男人负责。其他人也被认为与丽莎的遭遇有关，包括一个被称为清理女孩的女人。关于丽莎失踪时纳奈莫的背景。据报道，那里存在着繁荣的毒品交易。
As an Animo is a central location on Vancouver Island, with access along highway corridors, large amounts of drugs were said to be moved through there at the time. The Hell's Angels were very prominent and still do have a presence there, although the authorities have cracked down on them, seizing their clubhouse under the Civil Forfeiture Act, claiming that it could be used for criminal activity in the future. That seizure is actually still before the courts. The Hell's Angels are fighting it. Along with the Hell's Angels, it is said that there was an Asian triad presence in Animo,
由于纳奈莫是温哥华岛的中心位置，可以通过公路走廊，据说当时有大量的毒品通过那里运输。地狱天使（Hell's Angels）非常显眼，现在仍然在那里有存在，尽管当局已经对他们进行了打击，根据《民事没收法》没收了他们的会所，声称它将来可能被用于犯罪活动。那次没收实际上仍在法庭审理中。地狱天使正在抗争。除了地狱天使，据说纳奈莫还有亚洲三合会的存在，
as well as other crime figures. It's not publicly known whether or not police ever formally searched the house to which Lisa Marie Young was taken by Chris Adair in the early morning hours of the 30th of June 2002. There are other properties said to be connected with the case as well. It's not publicly known if they were searched either. All the police will say is it's an open case and if they suspect foul play. As for why Chris took Lisa to the house and what happened after they reached this location, we don't know.
以及其他犯罪人物。警方是否正式搜查了2002年6月30日清晨克里斯·阿代尔带丽莎·玛丽·杨去的那所房子，目前尚不公开。据说还有其他与此案有关的房产。目前也不公开他们是否被搜查过。警方只会说这是一个悬案，如果他们怀疑有犯罪行为。至于克里斯为什么把丽莎带到那所房子，以及他们到达那个地点后发生了什么，我们不得而知。
But clearly, there are people that do. And that's where the trail ends for Lisa's case. When you google the case, you'll get some newspaper articles and some basic facts. But if you dig a little deeper, you'll get taken down a rabbit hole to some very dark places. It's hard to talk about anonymous internet comments on the show. There's just no way to verify what is being said. And most are pretty vague and aren't that clear anyway. So I won't mention what they are.
但显然，有人知道。这就是丽莎案件线索的终点。当你谷歌这个案件时，你会得到一些报纸文章和一些基本事实。但如果你挖掘得更深一点，你会被带进一个兔子洞，进入一些非常黑暗的地方。在节目中谈论匿名的互联网评论很难。根本无法核实所说的话。而且大多数评论都很模糊，也不清楚。所以我不会提到它们是什么。
But it looks to be a case where there are people with the story to tell. We just need them to come forward and tell it. Unfortunately, the Youngs have been victims of numerous prank callers. On one call, the person said, I'm moving Lisa's body right now. The police managed to trace the call, but all they did was tell the caller not to ring again. Joanne Young still does everything she can to keep Lisa's memory alive.
但这看起来是一个有故事的人可以讲述的案件。我们只需要他们站出来讲述。不幸的是，杨氏夫妇一直是无数恶作剧电话的受害者。在一次通话中，那个人说，我正在移动丽莎的尸体。警方设法追踪了电话，但他们所做的只是告诉打电话的人不要再打来了。乔安妮·杨仍然尽其所能让丽莎的记忆鲜活。
She hands out pamphlets and still puts up posters, although some businesses are no longer as happy to put them up, grumbling about the clutter they create on their windows. The Youngs have organised a vigil and candlelight ceremony each year since Lisa's disappearance. Joanne believes there is more than one person who knows what happened to Lisa, and she prays that one of those people will come forward to finally give them closure. Until then, she is doing everything she can to make sure no one forgets. Alison Crowe was a friend of Lisa's.
她分发传单并仍然张贴海报，尽管一些企业不再那么乐意张贴它们，抱怨它们在窗户上造成的混乱。自丽莎失踪以来，杨氏夫妇每年都组织守夜和烛光仪式。乔安妮相信不止一个人知道丽莎发生了什么，她祈祷这些人中的一个能站出来，最终给他们一个了结。在那之前，她正在尽一切努力确保没有人忘记。艾莉森·克劳（Alison Crowe）是丽莎的朋友。
Alison is a musician, and she wrote a song called Lisa's Song. It is beautiful and touching, and is played at the vigils held for Lisa. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today.
艾莉森是一位音乐家，她写了一首名为《丽莎之歌》（Lisa's Song）的歌。它美丽而感人，在为丽莎举行的守夜活动中播放。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。
Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. Lisa's Song will close out the episode today. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。《丽莎之歌》将结束今天的节目。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。